welcome back to the david pakman show
welcome uh what's going on here I have a
correction I guess you could say yes and
I think think our audio level needs go
up a little bit you'd be the the expert
on that yeah let's do that okay um maybe
we can come down in the headphones a
little bit all right so yesterday we
were talking about clone troopers
stormtroopers and all of that and
apparently I made a mistake yes indeed
so I'm going to read it is Ian wrote in
and he said I'm mistaken about that's
all stormtroopers are clones so nerdy
talk follows he wrote clone troopers
commissioned for the Republic were
genetically modified clones designed to
rapidly age to battle ready status in
five years the side effects of this was
the clone troopers age unnaturally fast
and most were out of service by the time
of a new hope that being episode 4 uh so
clone troopers clones were expensive and
with the rapid expansion of the military
following the formation of the Galactic
Empire it was in practical and costly to
continue relying solely on clones for
their expanded military force instead
they open military academies started in
listing on some world's conscripted
soldiers by the time of a new hope most
storm troopers were regular humans and
30 years later there are likely no
clones left alive unless the Empire
still buys a small amount to use as an
elite fighting force indeed so my
understanding by mere coincidence that I
read something about it that it didn't
make sense for the UH for there to be a
black storm trooper that was actually an
unfair criticism right because they're
not clones I guess so yeah now this
could be a storm trooper who goes rogue
sure I don't know I haven't looked into
the story too much anyway let's talk
about life I what is life I it's a
method of delivering data wirelessly
that uses the visible spectrum light
visible light spectrum and it can
deliver internet access 100 times faster
Dave then what whatever we have going on
here sure I'm so this was it was tested
this week by in estonian startup called
Bell many in the capital of the talent
is that how how you prolly so okay they
used a life I enabled light bulb to
transmit data at speeds of up one
gigabyte per second but that laboratory
tests have shown theoretical speeds of
up to two hundred twenty four gigabytes
per second now what I want to remind
people of because when you hear this
it's so hugely exciting if I word if we
were to take our internet connection
here right and replace our gigabit or
whatever router with one that is ten
times faster our internet speed would
not change at all because it's still
limited by our internet service provider
so these technologies it's fascinating
it's terrific that this is going on but
we have to remember that you also need
an Internet service provider that can
actually give you those speeds in order
for your local transmission method to to
increase your speed now if there were an
Internet service provider that work
directly via live by in some way if that
were possible then you would sort of
beasts be skipping that step but I think
sometimes as confusion when people hear
about these technologies yeah but uh but
I mean also in theory you could have
like uh like a closed work network where
you have your traditional internet speed
coming in from your service provider and
then let's say you you know you use this
as a method of transferring data of
course um okay so it's a little bit
different but it could still be useful
but your rights it could but even then
at this point you'd be limited by the
speed of your hard drives yes uh so
anyway it's still pretty cool very very
cool and what we're talking about here
is actually using a light bulb right I
mean you can see the light and it's
transferring the data mm-hmm so that is
the term life I coined by professor
Harold Haas or haarahld Haas from
Edinburgh University this technology i
guess was demonstrated by him in a
2011 TED conference uh so this is pretty
good stuff it is interesting and you
know but you mentioned Estonia Estonia
is doing some very interesting things
I'm increasingly interested in visiting
Estonia it seems to be one of the parts
of Europe that is sort of straddling the
border between between being Western
Europe and being Eastern Europe
technologically it's a very advanced
country it's a small country it's still
a much from what I understand a much
less expensive vacation than a lot of
the more usual suspects people like to
go to in Europe and it just seems
super-interesting to go to and don't
they also have this then we talked about
the e citizenship thing in Estonia um
well I it's uh II citizenship but also
electronic voting right I bet you can do
from that I guess any computer very
interesting country yeah I think that's
I would also love to go there uh so I
guess when it comes to radio waves the
spectrum is is pretty small compared to
the spectrum of visible light and so
there's a you just have more room really
ten thousand times larger so the whole
thing great stuff we are going to keep
our eyes on life I and we may never even
we may never even use it in our
lifetimes but well I don't know about
that I think we will all right maybe the
technology is there okay a quick story
here on blackberry in Pakistan
blackberry I don't know who uses
blackberries anymore blackberry still a
thing somehow yeah but they are going to
exit Pakistan and exit isn't quotes but
the Pakistani government has basically
demanded that blackberry allow them to
monitor all the information coming
through their servers all the data all
the phone calls all the texts all back
door open wide open back door wide open
so they decided to exit the market
altogether is it did Pakistan just kind
of tell them they have to leave because
they denied them this whatever whatever
the case BlackBerry's leaving Pakistan
and uh a quote here from Marty beard the
chief operating officer at at blackberry
yep said that the truth of the matter
was that they want to look at all
traffic passing across messaging servers
that they would not comply what dave is
want to talk right into that Mike I
think right into the mic i'm looking at
my level is picking me up just fine good
good good okay um so anyway you threw me
off threw me off here remaining in
Pakistan would have meant for fitting
our commitment to protect our users
privacy that is a compromise we are not
willing to make I wonder what they're
handing over to the NSA well i was gonna
say fantastic they're taking a moral
stand they would rather lose the
business of pakistan then hand over data
and now what are they doing in the u.s.
that that's that was the obvious
question i thought of yeah they also
said that Pakistan is an important
market and that's you know it's nice to
know that this type of data collection
is happening in other places I I you
know it's great Pakistan certainly needs
it Pakistan probably needs it more than
we do maybe so but we know that they
have some corrupt officials anyway who
knows what's going on in that uh in that
government all right Dave you want to
tell a story i will tell a story of of
uh sometime you know it's been a while
since I ran into someone who just
presented completely shamefully
shamelessly rather uh stereotypes in
this case about Jews and it it really
came close to getting pretty ugly over
the over the thanksgiving weekend
haven't told the story to lose the cuffs
are not mystical but it was gonna get
very awkward but I decided I thought
better of it and said this person
doesn't know what the hell they're
talking about I let them just go away I
was speaking to someone it doesn't even
matter who it's someone I've only met a
few times right and as a complete non
sequitur I there was a conversation
about vehicles that's the only
connection people were talking about
vehicles it was me and this person and a
couple other people and this person says
yeah you know uh in some some city in
new york and i don't remember
the name of it but it's a city in New
York that has a significant Hasidic
Jewish population goes up you know in in
its mostly Hasidic Jews there and I'll
be driving on the highway and these
Hasidic Jews that they're never driving
the same speed as me they either drive
way past me going 90 miles an hour or
they're going super slow and getting in
my way and their cars always have like a
bumper hanging off the cars and in
terrible condition so so far basically
they're saying okay but Pacific Jews are
poor right i mean if you're saying their
cars are always in disrepair i guess
you're either saying they don't care
about their cars or it's a poor
population that can afford nice vehicles
and that's true the Hasidic Jewish
population is typically a poor
population no question about it is that
the conversation so far uh and I say
okay but don't you think maybe you're
you're sort of generalizing about a
group bit just based on a few people
that you've seen and the person goes no
no no I've researched this now at this
point a normal person if you're if you
say something that is generalizing about
a group of people and someone says to
you don't you think you're unfairly
generalizing a light bulb goes off and
you go maybe I'm being offensive maybe I
shouldn't be saying this no light bulb
went off okay person continues goes no
I've researched it see the thing is
acidic Jews can't negotiate anything
financial okay so they all leased
vehicles and when they leased vehicles
they have to negotiate either through
their rabbi or through a leasing company
and leasing companies so most people
when you lease a car you go to a
dealership and you negotiated with the
dealership there are leasing companies
that exist and i've i've gotten quotes
from them when i've been leasing
vehicles they make they basically deal
with dealerships and i think the idea is
the dealership accepts smaller profit
because the lease company can get them a
bunch of deals right so it sort of like
quantity / or quality and so right away
this theory is [ __ ] okay pardon my
language because they're simultaneously
saying they all have vehicles in
disrepair with bumpers hanging off and
they're all leasing brand new vehicles
now when you lease a vehicle you can't
have bumpers hanging off i mean the
vehicle has to be in
good shape because part of what you're
agreeing to do with the lease is return
it in good condition or pay for those
repairs right so the idea that the poor
Hasidic Jews with the broken cars can
simultaneously afford to regularly be
leasing new vehicles it's ridiculous
okay totally ridiculous uh and I said oh
okay um well what how how do you know
that they're leasing the vehicles and he
says well because their license plate
frames all have the name of a leasing
company in Brooklyn which of course in
my mind is right the Jews New York City
leasing finances new vehicle it's all
look clearly there's more to this story
this person clearly has a lot more to
say now at this point I was just so
taken aback by this hypothesis about
Jews with new cars that are negotiated
independently that are in disrepair and
they can't drive well they're either
speeding or they're going really slow
that I started saying less and less and
the person goes yeah and the reason they
drive so poorly is they believe God will
protect them so hey I'll go 90 or I'll
be on my phone not paying attention
because it's not in my hands it's in god
hands okay this so this is the total
hypothesis that this person had towards
the end I think they realize that I was
starting to find their commentary
offensive because they very quietly
after me just being totally silent said
you know but maybe this is just a small
slice of them maybe it's not
representative of everybody and then the
person disappeared from in front of me
and didn't say another word to me the
entire night other than a very awkward
goodbye I don't know if they realize
that they were doing something
completely insane and i told i told
former TV director my brother 'not on
about this and he's now working for the
anti-defamation league and he does a lot
of trainings on how to deal with
anti-semitism and xenophobia
anti-hispanic you know just all that
stuff and he said sometimes a really
good thing to say is ha that's
interesting what do you think this means
about jews or whatever group and his
explanation was if someone is willing to
tell this story right this is not the
only thing they've thought of with
regard to whatever group
they tell a story about Jews and cars
and leasing or whatever they clearly
have some ideas about Jews more
generally that are probably the really
offensive ideas and my brother said a
great thing to say if you don't want to
be confrontational but you want to sort
of suss out what it is this person
thinks which is probably really
offensive as you say that's that's
really interesting and and how does this
tie it like what does this mean about
Jews what does this say about Jews right
what can we deduce about Jews based on
this story and most people at that point
will either realize they're about to say
something horribly offensive or they'll
just tell you what the really offensive
thing they think is I didn't do that but
maybe I should have maybe next time do I
know this person you I don't think
you've ever met them now okay well
that's uh yeah that's pretty interesting
um I don't have any experience with
driving and Hasidic Jews in New York the
in you the stereotype in new york city
is that Hasidic Jews in Brooklyn often
Drive minivans because they have large
families and that sort of it that's true
there one of them but the the group's
acidic Jews are one of the groups that
have the highest number of offspring
children and you know you do need a
vehicle for that and oftentimes that the
sort of idea the stereotype is you see a
lot of Hasidic Jews driving around in
minivans I've never seen anything about
over least minivans or their minivans
with a bumper hanging off or their
minivans being driven very fast or very
slow and the funniest thing about that
is there either driving faster or slower
than me yeah the odds that cars are
driving the exact same speed you're
driving or pretty low most vehicles on
the road are gonna be driving either
faster or slower I don't know that
that's just acidic vehicles yeah that's
a good point like when people say oh
Jews just love money right because
asians and black people and wasps and
christians they hate money they don't
want anything to do with money Louis
yeah uh right like they're like the
fried chicken thing right right
everybody loves fried chick of course uh
anyway uh I think there's one thing I
can agree with from yachts whole
exchange and that is that i can totally
envision
pious Jewish muck speeding down the
highway because they think that God will
protect and that applies to every
religion as we type the woman recently
who was in a car crash because of rain
while driving because she was convinced
Jesus with it was gonna take care of her
she just needed to pray to Jesus while
driving yeah yeah that's that's
something that we can find across all
religions sure thing but it's disturbing
nevertheless so that's it for today
right anything yet I have nothing else
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com